-For those
who don't watch this show,
and that clip
is the first thing they've seen,
they might be surprised to know
that this is a show
that takes place
in the Marvel Universe.
-That's right.
-Yes.
This is a very trippy show that
exists in that superhero world.
You played --
Your character was a vessel
for a villain
called The Shadow King.
-That's right. I started out
as a human being, maybe,
in the first episode
of season one, and then I died.
And then, an evil psychic mutant
villain took over my body.
[ Light laughter ]
And now I'm just
kind of floating around
in the Astral Plane,
trying to figure out
how to get out of another
dimension of time and space.
-Yeah!
-Well explained.
Very well explained.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You did a great job.
Do you find this is a show --
If people ask me about my show,
I say, "Oh, it's a talk show.
I interview guests."
You obviously --
Your task is a lot harder.
-Yeah, I know. I just actually
texted Noah Hawley and said,
"How do I explain this show?
Why don't you tell me."
And he said, "Say it's like
going to home-ec class on acid."
[ Laughter ]
-A good way to describe it.
And Noah Hawley,
who's a fantastic writer
and also created the show
"Fargo", he created this show.
And he also, when the show --
Before the show started,
I guess,
he created playlists
for you guys?
-Yeah.
Yeah, that's something
I really like about him.
He sent us all these, like,
Spotify playlists
that I guess were just
kind of to inspire us.
And a lot of it was, like,
Pink Floyd
and really cool songs.
And then tracks of just people
screaming into trash cans.
[ Laughter ]
And just, like, kind of really
unpleasant ambient tracks
that's really weird to listen to
in the car when you're driving.
-Now, the first time
you put it on,
were you surprised
when the first
scream into a trash can came on?
-Yeah, yeah.
I was, I was shocked.
I thought someone was behind me,
screaming in a trash can.
-And that was Jemaine Clement,
who's a fantastic actor.
One of the
Flight of the Conchords guys.
He was in that scene.
And that, obviously, is a very
well-choreographed scene.
Do you enjoy that part of it?
-Um, I --
It was really hard.
I've never had
professional dance training.
And I don't know if Jemaine has.
I don't think he has.
[ Laughter ]
But we were just told, like,
"Show up, 10:00 a.m.
for your dance lessons
that will go on
for seven hours every day."
And we were just thrown in there
with a bunch
of professional choreographers,
and we just kind of
had to, like, fake it.
-How long --
How many days did you rehearse
before you shot the scene?
-Like a week.
Maybe more than a week.
-Wow!
-It was intense.
-It paid off.
You looked great.
-Thanks.
-Yeah.
-I was scared. It was hard,
but I got through it.
-Well, I'm glad you did.
-Thank you.
-The show does seem fairly
physically demanding.
-Yeah, there's a lot of weird,
like, stunts and animals.
And just, uh...
I'm just rolling around
in the dirt a lot.
[ Laughter ]
I don't really know
what I'm doing.
-I want to ask about this,
because I have
also done this recently.
I have not seen results.
You did -- You took a DNA test.
-That's right.
-What brought it about?
-I know you've been waiting
to hear my results
for a while, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm gonna tell you
what I am now.
-Okay, great.
-Yeah, I did the --
-Did you have to desire
to know what you were?
-Yeah, well, I heard Oprah said
that it was, like,
the best Christmas present
to get people or something.
-Okay, gotcha.
-23andMe.
-Yeah.
-So I just do whatever she says.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And I did it.
I spit into the tube,
and I sent it
into the science factory.
[ Laughter ]
Or, you know...
And then, I got it back.
And so here's what I am.
I'm like 30% Irish...
-Uh-huh.
-...which I kind of knew.
I'm like 30% Spanish,
I'm 8% West African.
-All right.
-Um, I'm 7% Native American.
-Wow.
-This is really
only interesting to me.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so sorry.
I'm 1% Ashkenazi Jewish...
-Oh, wow.
-...which I, like...
-Yeah.
-...totally didn't know.
I'm really .6, but I'm
rounding up for that one.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-And I made homemade
matzah ball soup recently, so...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
Did you feel it --
[ Applause ]
You all of a sudden knew --
You all of a sudden knew,
"This is a part of me"?
-Well, once I got
the results in, I was like,
"I'm just gonna go for it."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you feel like you'll be
making other sort of commitments
to your newfound 1% Judaism?
-Yeah, um, definitely.
I'm gonna do all the stuff
they do, um, in the book.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I also
had some interesting variance.
I have a Neanderthal variance
that is associated
with having less back hair,
which I thought was interesting.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
And does that track
with, uh, your back?
-Big-time.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
That's spot on.
-That's great.
That seems to me to be a DNA
result that I wouldn't need.
-Yeah,
I don't know what that one does.
-Like, at this point in my life,
I know where I'm at
on back hair.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, yeah.
I think, like, maybe
way back in the day,
you needed a lot of back hair
for survival, maybe.
-Yeah.
-As some kind of
defense against...
-I would like to know, like --
When I get my test back,
I'd like to know
what my ear-hair
situation's gonna be.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want to know
about mine.
-You don't want to know?
-No, not the ears.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you can just brush hair
over it as you get older.
-That's right.
-If it gets bad.
-I try to hide my ears
as often as possible.
[ Laughter ]
-It is always
so lovely to see you.
Congrats on all
your percentages.
-Thank you.
-As well as the show.
It's so great
to see you, Aubrey.
-Thank you.
-Thanks for being here.